the very thing we used our whole life to
get what we want
for something greater to happen
absolutely that's such a paradox and the
moment you step in it honors free will
so then
so then the person who's who's the new
age person who's saying well i'm just
going to wait for my maserati to come to
me
this is not how that works
once you move into a new state of being
and you're creating wealth in other
words only gold creates gold lead
doesn't create gold and our job is to
take those base emotions of anger and
resentment and fear and anxiety those
base emotional emotions and transmute
them into gold because right on the
other side of our pain is freedom right
on the other side of our lack is wealth
of abundance right on the other side of
our fear is courage it's the same energy
it's just trapped in the body and when
we transmute that energy into something
else right
now
now we have available energy to begin to
design a destiny with so then a person
who moves into that elegant state of
being where they're expanded and they're
enriched and they're in love with life
then
they can't go back to the old self you
know because that is their new state of
being so then if you practice that every
day sooner or later it's going to begin
to become familiar to you and you'll you
and you may feel it you may see things
you may hear from it i mean there are
means of communications that can be set
up it's going through that point so then
if you're creating wealth yes and you're
in the state of being of abundant you
better not be thinking lacking thoughts
because an abundant person would never
do that hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and use the law
of attraction to manifest some money
enjoy
rule number two know what you really
want with bob proctor what do you want
them to do what do you who do who do you
want them to be where would you like
them to start i'd like to ask them to
ask themselves what do i really want in
this life
what do i really want
and take a pen
and write it down
[Music]
what do i really want in this life
they might start out
what do i love doing
i think that's where you start your
purpose in life is what do you love
i'm living my purpose see your purpose
is why you're alive why you get out of
bed in the morning
and some people never figure that out
they never even give it any thought
when it's
probably the most important question a
person can ask themselves
if you started what do i really love
doing that's a good place to start
you know i had a
doctor here
probably a couple of years ago now in
phoenix
he was in a seminar and he said
he was telling me he was thinking of
quitting the medical profession i said
why are you going to quit
well he said you got to put in a lot
more time to earn less money today and i
said well i've heard that
he said the medical profession's all
messed up and they said well i've heard
that too
i said why did you become a doctor
well he said i'd love it
why would you want to
quit well he said because you can't earn
i said wait a minute
i said if you're doing what you love
if you never earned a dime
you're spending your days doing what you
love to do that's a trick of life
i said your problem is you think you
earn money by going to work you work to
earn money you don't work to earn money
people earn the most money don't work at
all
you earn money by providing service
but you gain satisfaction from doing
what you love
and there's two forms of income one
satisfaction the other is money
it's a material thing
but i said if you're not getting
satisfaction of what you do you should
quit it
because they said
that's where it comes in that's why we
should figure out what we love to do
and then dedicate our life to it
i got into this business
i had been studying it for quite a while
and i had the opportunity already
mentioned a visiting early night yale
1966
and i was leaving his office right at
the end and i said earl what is the big
deal in life
well he said there isn't any big deal
bobby he said
it's simply a matter of sitting and
figuring what you love to do and
then dedicate your life to it so the
problem with most people is they never
figure out what they love to do well i'm
telling i could feel the hair going up
in the back of my neck i knew exactly
what i love to do i would love to do
what he was doing i was and i wanted to
do it with him
i had a very busy company at the time
we're operating canada the us and
england
but i knew that i was finished doing
that i was going to come back i was
going to work with him two years later i
was his vice president of sales i wanted
to do in the what he was doing be in the
business he was in
and that's where i made the decision and
i love it i love what i do
now
that's what people should be doing what
do i love to do then dedicate your life
to it now you earn money by providing
service you can earn money while you're
sleeping just figure out how to serve
people
you don't have to be there you don't
have to physically be there and do it
you can serve people while you're
sleeping and get paid
and that's how you're in money so you
got to learn how to earn money but that
has got nothing to do with
a life
of living what you love that's the first
place so if i was telling anybody
sit down figure out what you love to do
and then make up your mind you're going
to dedicate your life to it
what stops most people what they love to
do they think you can't earn any money
at it that doesn't matter
forget about the money
that's another subject figure out how to
earn it go talk to people and not earn
money i know how to earn money i can
teach people how to earn money but that
is not the thing is to provide service
so the most important thing what do i
love to do sit down what would i really
love to do how would i love to spend my
life
that's what we should do
and unfortunately
most people never get involved in that
exercise rule number three rewire your
brain with bruce lipton how do you
rewire your brain
well as we just said the first thing you
have to do is say what the heck are my
programs you don't have to fix a program
if it works
the only one you want to fix is the one
that doesn't work so then you say well
what are the programs and i can already
tell you the things that don't work in
your life that you desire to have in
your life and you are creating an effort
and a struggle and a lot of work to make
it happen the reason why it's not
working is because somewhere in the
program it doesn't support that
conclusion so this program does not
allow you to have this
so the thing is well as long as i have
this program i'm never going to get this
and even if i get it it's going to
disappear if i you know
as soon as i let go of the control it's
going to disappear because it's
sabotaging it away
so the first thing is identify well
where are you having trouble
and i said whatever that destination is
that the thing you were looking for
whether it was a job health relationship
whatever
if that's where you're having a trouble
recognize this
the program is counter to that
it's the opposite the program is the
opposite that's why this can't stay here
because this is going to 95 of the day
create a different program
not the one you want it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four manifest
effortlessly with rhonda byrne one of
the things is we've all been driven to
achieve and you know struggle to get
somewhere and you've got to work really
hard you know to get money there's a
belief you know no you don't you know
it's that's not the case all of the time
at all and so we we like struggle and
pushed an effort effort effort and the
most extraordinary thing is this
is that the more effortless you are
the greater you manifest everything that
you ever dreamt of
yes because
right because when you have effort you
were saying i don't have this
you know you're saying i don't have it
and the university is i don't have it
you know and so so when you're efforting
you're like i don't have it i'm not
worthy enough i need to work harder i
need to really struggle but if you are
just completely effortless everything
just comes because there's no resistance
stopping any of it
there's a lot of i'm a big fan of this
but i also understand the principle of
uh working hard as an athlete i would
have to wake up early train to grow
learn my craft and put in you know years
of practice
that was hard work you know it's yeah i
gotta grow my muscles it's not growing
you know effortlessly at that age so for
and some business owners will say you
know the key to building a successful
business is
you know working hard building the right
team but showing up consistently every
day
what would you say to that
thought uh around hard work and for a
lot of people as an athlete then you
would definitely know those times when
you perform brilliantly and it was
average
where you yeah
right it was that you're in the zone
where you're in the zone you're in the
flow yeah it's just extraordinary you
know
it's like something is moving your body
you're not it's just like you it's the
most incredible thing and actors too
have the same experience they will have
this moment when they're on stage or
acting and suddenly the ego is not there
and they are just flowing like it is
incredible and i heard an actor talk
about that and say all actors crave for
that moment
you know and so when that because effort
comes from the ego and from the mind
that's where it all comes from so
so
we can do and achieve and have all of
those things without all of that
effort yeah yeah what's the difference
between i guess there's still level of
needing to master your craft though
right like you became a great producer
and a director and creator
that doesn't come
after two days of not working on your
craft right because you worked on your
craft for
a decade or two until
you had the skill set the knowledge the
wisdom to them yeah put out what you
needed to hmm
you're still doing things and
this is the thing because if being
effortless doesn't mean you're not doing
things
what it means is there's no effort in
what you're doing
so it's it's so you're still doing
things but it's effortless like you were
still working out but it was effortless
and so
because the minute you feel like you're
struggling that's the mind and that's
the ego stepped in and then it's not
flowing you know and and people will
find when they're struggling you know
there's that goes wrong and then that
goes wrong and that goes wrong and so
you still do things and i still did all
of those things like before the secret i
did everything with effort full effort
one thousand percent hard work
yeah total queen of effort
and you were lacking and you were
lacking abundance
you were lacking big results and
yeah yeah and so now i do like i
i
sat down to do this book this book was
absolutely effortless really oh
oh my gosh
absolutely and the most effortless book
that i have written for sure i mean
amazing really amazing and so when i was
writing the seal wrote the secret in two
and a half weeks two and a half weeks
because it just like wow because i'd
made the documentary i'd done all these
practices
i knew what i wanted to share all of the
things that i wanted to share in the
secret and so i mean we spent you know
about six weeks in the editing process
of it but it just came like a rush
and that two and a half weeks was
effortless
and when i did this book it was
effortless and i and there have been
books that i've gone to right where it's
been a lot of effort really you know
yeah yeah and i and i just have to stop
because i remember i wrote a book and i
never published it and it was all effort
and it was you're forcing it you were
yeah forcing it and so then what you're
writing about is you're just writing a
whole lot of recycled stuff that the
mind is turning up and you are not
receiving things from beyond the mind
and you want to have things beyond the
mind rule number five clear negative
thoughts with gabby bernstein if you're
in a negative place you're not going to
immediately start attracting horrible
things into your life but the cumulative
effect of that negativity starts to
one block what you really want and to
obviously create more more disturbances
so we
through the power of our thoughts and
our belief systems our actions and our
words we can
claim a new
energy a new feeling really a new way of
feeling
that feeling
is what
supports our attracting power or blocks
it there's two levels of showing up for
your negative thoughts one level is the
reprogramming process which i can talk
about which i refer to as a process that
i've coined the choose again method
which i'll teach
and another one is
doing like i said deeper therapeutic
practices going
going and finding that
internal family systems therapist or
that person who does emdr eye movement
desensitization and reprocessing i can
explain all of these and going in and
doing deeper
truly neuro
neuro like really changing your neural
pathways and undoing
the habitual effects of the fight flight
freeze response so it's both it's it's
it and many people can start that
journey of undoing their thought forms
through practices that they find in
self-help books like super attractor so
i think i'm like a gateway to deeper
further for further modalities i'm not a
therapist although i have had uh decades
of deep dive therapy so i am excited i
am a
very uh seasoned
therapized human
yes
but um but but i uh so i so i wanted to
talk about it from those two levels
because level one is starting to notice
the negative thoughts and this is the
choose again method that i teach notice
those negative thoughts that you have on
repeat and the first step is to notice
the thought and how it makes you feel
and this is such a big brave step of
just becoming aware and conscious of the
negative thought forms that are standing
in your way and so that's step one
notice and how does it make you feel the
second step is to forgive yourself for
having the thought because
when we have a thought that we keep
thinking as abraham hicks says it
becomes a belief a belief is just a
thought that you keep thinking so if you
forgive yourself and say oh my god
there's just that thought i keep
thinking again i forgive myself
that step
takes the pressure off takes the and
it separates you the individual from the
thought oh that's just a thought i keep
thinking it's not who i am got that step
two and then step three is the fun part
which is to reach for the next best
feeling thought so if the negative
thought is i gained 17 pounds this year
so let's use that negative thought i
gained 17 pounds as you're doing ivf for
a year when you're on medication every
single day for 365 days you're going to
gain weight and so
i i gained a lot of more weight than
i've gained other than being pregnant
and for someone who isn't accustomed to
that and so i don't want to be in any
way insensitive because many people
struggled with this their entire lives
and they're going to be like screw you
gabby you have one time in your life
where this is a struggle f off
but um it was you know i'm a woman so
here i was and i gained the 17 pounds
and you know people were like saying
things on the internet like what did you
do to your face and like you look like
you put too much filler in and i'm like
you i gained 17 pounds
and so what did i do to choose again so
notice the thought and how it makes me
feel what makes me feel frustrated and
it keeps coming back forgive myself for
having the thought okay so that is a
thought that i keep thinking and it's
not you know i can forgive myself
completely for that thought
step three choose again so here's how i
would choose again in that case all
right gabby listen you didn't look that
great when you were underweight so let's
let's let's be grateful for some of
these extra pounds and you know what
gabby now you have a healthier baseline
so maybe you don't want to be at 17
pounds maybe you want to be 10 pounds
more than you were before and you know
what you were doing this in the pursuit
of making a child and your body needs
more weight on your body to to conceive
and your 41 year old woman and how
amazing it is that you have the
resources to be able to have insurance
to do this process and to be able to go
through this and what a privilege and a
luxury and you know even though it's
been frustrating you had so much fun
while you were driving to these hour
away appointments but it was the only
time that i got out of the house for
covid and it was the time that i was
really studying and learning new things
and i could keep going and going and
going did you see how i'm talking about
it and there's nothing negative anymore
it's just like that was a great process
this is okay you know and now i can have
fun
cleansing and clearing and and and see
myself getting back to a healthy place
and just really
thinking your way out talking your way
out and rule number six the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
visualize the steps with mel robbins you
must
visualize the steps that lead you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal
this is a major mistake that people make
they
manifest improperly because all they do
is focus on the end goal
if you've ever made a vision board
think about what you put on the vision
board you put up just the beach house or
the million dollars in the bank are you
crossing the finish line or you
launching that business or you having
the body that you want are you a driving
the maserati whatever it is the end goal
is what you put up on a vision board
that is not what you're going to do when
you manifest if you start focusing on
crossing the finish line of the marathon
that is a one-way ticket to being
unmotivated and completely discouraged
in fact research shows that if all you
do is focus on the thing that you want
and you just focus on that vision of you
and your bikini body or you with the
love of your life on your arms or you at
the
oscars winning that award or the grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal you start to
feel really unmotivated and discouraged
because you're nowhere near it
that's where manifesting comes in
because we're not going to focus on the
end goal
you got to pick something that you want
in order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end
it's about the bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects
where you are right here with what you
dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be
but when it comes to manifesting
once you've given yourself permission to
dream with the lid off and really want
what you want to feel the pull of that
thing now we got to talk about the path
that connects where you are with where
you want to go
and this is all about visualizing the
little steps there's a lot of research
that proves why visualizing the steps
is
the most important thing that you could
do
there was a study done at ucla for
example
where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a
close their eyes visualize in their mind
and feel in their body
themselves taking the test
and then walking up
to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an a plus
that's what group a the vision board
group were told to do to visualize
themselves achieving what they wanted
group b
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room
sitting down at the desk
and studying
and staying up late and putting in the
work studying and preparing for the
tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it group b
the hard work group
the group that was taught to close their
eyes and visualize and seeing themselves
doing the work to study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered group b
you got the correct answer the reason
why group b
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work
and it's only through actions that you
will get the result that you want
preparing your mind and visualizing
yourself doing it
lowers your resistance and leads to you
taking the action that's why manifesting
works
the law of attraction definitely works
most people just get it wrong most
people only focus on the thinking part
and not the most important part which is
the action right law of attraction it's
the last five letters that matter a c t
i o a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're going to focus on your new goal
your new habit the new thing that you
want into your life amazing you believe
that it's possible amazing you're
putting up a vision board with it on
your wall amazing you're researching and
watching videos like this every day
amazing that's great that's the first
starting point but nothing happens until
you take action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but
you're still just going to be this super
smart super ambitious person sitting at
home not achieving your goals you have
to do something i look at my youtube
channel as an example uh my main channel
i want to get the 10 million subscribers
that's my next goal right we hit one we
hit two i gotta hit ten
uh at the rate that we're growing it's
not fast enough like it's gonna take me
way too many years to make it happen so
i need to apply more pressure against it
so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be you know one of the first
uh thought leaders experts business
person to have 10 million subscribers on
a youtube channel it's my next goal
great writing that down every day
doesn't make sure that it's going to
happen what am i doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team
this week i want to go back and update
all of the thumbnails in all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6
000 videos imagine doing split tests on
all of those videos
i asked for 10 a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is going
to be and then the other one's doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't so this is our test
and if it works awesome i might have
that become somebody's full-time job so
that we can do 20 slit tests a day 40
split tests a day 100 split deaths a day
i don't know
but it's happening through action right
so it starts with the idea if you have
the idea but you're not taking action
you won't get results if you just have
the action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're going in circles
without any clear direction most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important i do it every
day it's why i create all these channels
i think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then you still have to go take the
second step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a
three-point landing question because i
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
netflix all day when you get home for
five hours and then go to sleep right
you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore your new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you are not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's the
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big ambitions big dreams for
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was a
famous physicist in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine
when in fact it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conhenry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe is immaterial
it's mental
and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it's mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part and the reality
about it why is that and so important as
uh sad vijay had just mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who's having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard cohn henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right
i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this
we
are creating this world and then i say
your mind is creating this world and
then i give you the science that says
there are two minds that are operating
at the same time one is called the
conscious mind and one is called the
subconscious mind i say what's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind
it's not a creative mind the
subconscious mind is habits things that
you've learned and you experienced in
your life and they become habits so uh
the subconscious mind is not thinking
creating a subconscious mind push the
button
play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh i wish i had this and
i desire that and these are the things i
want
and then you go out and start the day
and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science has recognized 95 percent
of the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging
and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have
and then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator
of your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have
uh an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects uh
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition so if the environment signals
the gene and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this and now
they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at 8 in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so
that's when the person makes the same
choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling
okay i'll complain just so i can feel
suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and you're tweeting and you're
instagramming and facebooking whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you you can check
your cell phone you can shower you can
have your coffee but when i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not gonna live in
the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else everything or to keep our
minds the way we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and
haphazard
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
lore
on a certain day
a man took a walk
he went for a long walk
accidentally unawares
he walked into paradise fortunate isn't
he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
paradise
after this long walk
he felt
a little
tired so he thought oh i'm tired
i wish i could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which
there was
very cushiony grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there
and slept
after a few hours he woke up
[Music]
well rested
and he thought oh i'm well rested
but i'm feeling hungry i wish i had
something to eat
[Music]
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they are the
services like that
[Music]
hungry people don't ask questions
food came and he
ate became full
then he thought
oh my stomach is full
i wish i had something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink he thought about it and all of
them just appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know charles darwin told you
all of you were monkeys your tail fell
away not me charles darwin told you
that you were all monkeys and your tail
fell away and then you became human yes
definitely the tail fell away but the
monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as marketa which means a monkey
why we are referring to the mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's
unnecessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is
if i say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean
imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to
learn it from the monkey you can teach
it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around
thought what the hell is happening here
i asked for food food came
i asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they're going to
surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghost surrounded him and
started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me
and he died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kulp of rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghost
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these
kalpa rukshas in the forest
you can barely find
a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a culprit
if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life energies are
organized in one direction once you are
like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so
organizing our minds
and
in turn organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now
in one direction if you do this you are
a kalpa ruksha yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important
that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because
we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from
a compulsive state of activity to a
conscious state of activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they asked for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now
let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh i want to build
a house to build a house i need 50 lakhs
but i have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying i don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying i don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith
in a god or in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded faith works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a child like person
who has a simple faith
in his god or his temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says shiva i
want a house i don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple act of faith
now he believes shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is shiva going to come and build your
house no i want you to understand god
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as god
is a source of creation
as a creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it
in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but
if you want life to happen the way you
want it because right now the very crux
of your happiness and your well-being is
this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is
life is not happening the way you think
it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is
it should happen
you're unhappy if life happens the way
you think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with
how much focus you think
how much
stability is there in your thought
and how much reverberance is there in
the thought process will determine
whether your thought will become a
reality or is it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible
is something possible or not possible
he's destroying humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want one of the things i've had to
do in my life is clear
some of the blockages that i've had and
you know
all in different ways all through
different people and that's something
that i may want to get more detailed in
with people too because people are going
to say well how do i clear these
blockages within me
and there are many many ways and many
people that peoples that i've met with
that have been able to you know help me
and you know i used to have a worryman
of money was one of them just like you
can inherit
your parents hair or you can inherit
their eyes or you can inherit there you
know i remember my dad used to be like i
used to smile just like you did you know
so you can inherit a smile you can also
inherit someone's
fears you can also inherit someone's
beliefs that aren't in alignment with
you know your own and you feel very
conflicted
uh you can inherit
uh just a lot of you can inherit a pain
you can inherit racism
and you could be like well i'm not a
racist person but i know i know someone
who's like bro i'm not a racist person
but then
they call every black person a kid
you know he's good that's a good kid and
i'm like
you got to watch yourself a little bit
man that's like
you know just pay attention to that
because you don't refer to people who
are who look like you as a kid
and you might refer to somebody who's a
kid that's the same age almost the same
age as you you know so it's like
you inherit these things you may not
even realize it right and
it's important to just do the work on
yourself because to push the next it's
like also breaking generational curses
it's like
i broke one of the blockages i had and
now my family uh we are living
we are getting more of our dreams uh my
mom is doing things that she never
thought she would do my dad my brother
you know um
we grew up in debt essentially and we i
had to break that that was one of the
blocks i had to break was uh the block
of money of not just be scared to have
money
feel like there's a scarcity of money
and it's not you know it's all just
energy right and you can have as much
energy as
needed
and uh
to clear all these blocks but
um to get back to my point it is so
important to go through these blocks and
these traumas
because when you pass it on to not only
just the next generation you pass it on
to the people around you your friends
your family you know you are you are the
company you keep
and the more
like-minded and better you are the the
better everyone around you is included
in your family right and you guys can
have the opportunity to
do anything that is possible anything
you want any any empire any business any
ownership things that you didn't even
know was imaginable but it all starts
with you working on yourself and that's
the importance of
you know the traumas it's almost like
well why would i want to correct you
know cancer runs in our family breast
cancer runs in our family why would i
want to correct that well you want to
correct that so you don't pass it on
and you know the vibration of cancer is
a low vibration you know what i'm saying
so
you know
uh it's important to take care of
ourselves and get rid of that trauma but
okay that was beaut but i'm so glad you
went there yeah i'm so happy you went
there because that the idea of being
aware of what we're inheriting
is so important especially when you when
that we are aware of we inherit what we
wear and how we think and how we look
but then
how we behave how we communicate how we
talk to people how we think about people
yeah how we think about women how we
think about men now
oh that's a good one how you thinking
about women and men yeah you know that's
another thing or or them how you think
about trans how do you think about lgbtq
like just like ever just how we think
about other
i'm so glad you went there i just wanted
to say that i'm so happy you took us on
that yeah i can just imagine like aliens
or people from another world being like
man these people really tripped that
they
have different shades of
skin they really be like it's just they
really kill each other over this like
you know i've never seen a cow look at
another cow and be like
you're a brown cow you're a
black and white cow i don't want to be
around you like nah they don't know it's
like you know and it makes me realize
that like if we kill each other and hate
each other over things like that or who
we love right or things that even have
nothing to do with us
then i wonder how we would handle an
extraterrestrial or an alien or really
something that is really different like
you know i always i'm like maybe that's
why the government or whoever doesn't
ever want to really break it to humanity
because who how are we going to react
you know but that's a whole other
conversation
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn to apply the law of
attraction check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you can start right now number one
is examine your relationship with money
because you do have a relationship with
money do you worry about it slipping
through your fingers do you hold on to
it are you scared of spending when